the fight over a bill to help struggling
americans remain
stuck in partisan divisions on capitol
hill democrats want a massive stimulus
keeping federal unemployment help at 600
a week republicans want a much smaller
package
the president says if there is no deal
he's prepared to take executive action
as soon as today mijijang reports from
the white house
we're very far apart it's most
unfortunate
congressional democrats and white house
negotiators emerged from
a three-hour plus meeting on capitol
hill with no deal
i would say we're closer on a lot of
issues we're still very far apart
on some very significant issues as some
30 million americans wait in financial
limbo for enhanced
unemployment benefits to be restored
each side blamed
the other we could have passed a very
skinny deal that dealt with some of the
most pressing
issues when they said a skinny proposal
it was anorexic
and democratic leaders said executive
action is not a solution
economic recovery was billed as the
theme of president trump's trip to ohio
thursday where the state's governor did
not greet him on the tarmac
as planned after testing positive for
coven 19 just
hours earlier we want to wish him the
best he'll be
fine governor mike dewine was first
tested with the white house's antigen
test that provides results
quickly but later that afternoon his
results were negative
after taking a more sensitive test it
prompts questions about the reliability
of the one dewine received from the
white house
and in an expected move president trump
has signed an executive order
against tick-tock deeming it a threat to
national security
it bans quote any transaction with the
app's chinese parent company
bite dance and will go into effect in 45
days but tick tock is
fighting back in a new statement this
morning they say they'll make sure the
rule of the law
is followed if not by the administration
than by the u.s
court the president has threatened to
quote close down
tick tock if microsoft or another
company does not acquire it but this
order does not explain
how he plans to do that it's also
unclear how it will affect the
millions of tick tock users here in the
u.s
jeff okay ouija thank you